françois fillon bonsoir qui allez-vous
soutenir écoutez ce premier tour n'a
rien réglé en réalité car les deux
candidats qui se retrouve au second tour
sont justement les deux candidats qui
avaient choisi de ne pas trancher la
question fondamentale de la ligne
politique du rpr est ce que nous sommes
une formation libéral et centriste une
sorte de cd ou à la française
ou est-ce que nous sommes au contraire
un parti républicain et sociales et moi
avec 25% des électeurs j'entends
maintenant continuer le combat pour que
le rpr affirme son identité républicaine
et sociale et surtout pour qu'ils se
réconcilient avec charles pasqua parce
que je pense que la famille gaulliste ne
peut pas restés divisés alors évidemment
il faut choisir et j'ai reçu les deux
candidats
je les ai écoutés et j'ai choisi
d'apporter mon soutien à michèle alliot
marie
pourquoi je les fais pour deux raisons
d'abord parce que les modernes parce que
c'est une femme d'abord parce que c'est
elle qui m'a donné le plus de garanties
que la sensibilité que je représente
seraient entendus et serait à sa place
au coeur du mouvement et puis ensuite
parce que c'est vrai qu'elle est belle
incarne plus le renouvellement plus
fille la modernité et qu'elle me semble
plus apte à continuer l'effort de
démocratisation de rénovation que
philippe séguin avait commencé et dont
ce premier tour a été une très belle
illustration clairement françois fillon
jean paul delevoye ont dit que c'était
le candidat de jacques chirac d'élise et
dont vous n'avez pas voulu choisir le
candidat de jacques chirac
je crois que tous ceux qui ont voulu
mouiller le président de la république
dans cette élection lui ont rendu un
mauvais service
la vérité c'est que tous les militants
du hak jacques chirac jean paul delevoye
non c'était en tout cas ce qu'affirmait
son entourage tous les militants que
j'ai rencontrés pendant cette campagne
soutiennent le président de la
république simplement beaucoup d'entre
eux pensent que la gestion de la
cohabitation et en particulier la place
du rpr pendant cette cohabitation n'a
pas été celle qu'elle aurait dû elle
pendant la campagne faisait notamment
déclaré je crois que ce télégramme de
brest mes concurrents proposent des
recettes de cuisine vous allez quand
même rentrer dans la cuisine et je vais
faire entrer dans la cuisine pour faire
entendre ma voix pour défendre mes idées
différentes opinions vos concurrents
je trouve que la campagne qu'ils ont
fait l'un et l'autre étaient une
campagne qui portait plus sur
l'organisation du mouvement le sur les
débats de fond
mais quand vous avez dit aux seconds je
gagnerai si le rpr veut changer vous
êtes sentiment qui veut pas vraiment
changé j'ai le sentiment qu'il n'ya
qu'un quart des militants qui veulent
vraiment changé et aujourd'hui pour moi
le pari c'est d'essayer d'en convaincre
d'autres alors par exemple vous avez
demandé une procédure interne contre
jean tiberi est ce que pense avec michel
n'arrive à vous suivre
je pense que michèle alliot-marie devra
si elle est élue régler cette question
dans un délai très court parce qu'elles
pèsent sur l'avenir du rpr lourdement
vous avez vous êtes prononcés contre le
projet de révision constitutionnelle et
du conseil supérieur de la magistrature
vous pensez que michèle alliot-marie
vous suivra et donc sera un désaccord
avec jacques chirac
en tout cas moi je défendrai la position
qui est la mienne et j'essaierai de la
faire partager au plus grand nombre
je pense que cette réforme est une
mauvaise réforme qui est contraire à
l'esprit même de nos institutions vous
allez faire pour rester hors pair vous
sentez proche de charles pasqua vous
êtes un fidèle de philippe seguin et
vous allez avec des gens qui sont pas
franchement sur vos idées je vous fais
remarquer d'abord philippe séguin est
toujours au rdr et que nous pensons
toujours qu'il est possible qu'ils aient
d'opérer ans il est toujours ou rp oui
mais ils reviennent à la responsabilité
des repères un jour non je crois que
c'est pas le sujet aujourd'hui la
d'autres réflexions et d'autres
ambitions mais il est toujours rpr il
inspire toujours une bonne partie du
courant de pensée que j'ai essayé de
représenter dans cette élection
et moi je crois encore à la possibilité
de refaire du rpr
cette formation républicaine et sociale
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure je n'ai
pas pu obtenir la majorité des militants
je continue le combat et françois fillon
vous êtes favorable à des accords
électoraux avec le rpf oui je suis
favorable à des accords électoraux avec
le rpf car je ne vois pas comment nous
pourrions rejetée charles pasqua qui
était encore il ya six mois dans nos
rangs au profit par exemple d'accords
électoraux avec l'udf qui sont
finalement plus éloignés de malheur en
fait avec patrick devedjian avec les
voix que vous représentez michèle
alliot-marie maintenant quasiment assuré
de devenir présidente du rpr
si elle est élue considérez-vous après
tout ce qu'on a dit c'est un désaveu
pour jacques chirac je crois que tous
ceux en qui encore une fois ont voulu
donner une signification à cette
élection par rapport au président de la
république se sont trompés en vérité la
signification profonde de cette élection
ce sera quand même le choix des
militants d'une certaine autonomie par
rapport aux entourages
ils n'ont pas aimé qu'on leur confie ce
que la démocratie c'est la première fois
qu'il y avait un vrai débat au sein du
rpr et on a voulu leur imposer un
candidat ils sont pas laissés
impressionner
merci françois fillon